good health now sponsored by partners in
primary care
as the open enrollment period continues
we want to welcome partners in primary
care to town
rocky got a tour of one of their new
locations to see just what they're all
about
hello dr wakefield hey good morning and
welcome to our
south nellis location of partners in
primary care
to be safe let's get you screened for
covet 19.
hi hi good morning can i have you start
with hand sanitizer of course
and then do you have you experienced any
flu like symptoms no in the last 14 days
have you traveled outside of the state
or country
no okay we're gonna take your
temperature okay
perfect you're good to go all right i'm
ready for my tour hi
of the new state-of-the-art facilities
in here well thank you
absolutely first i want to kind of point
out what our
traditional waiting room looks like and
and i think the real focus here is we
want patients to feel like they're at
home
right not necessarily in a sterile
medical clinic
in all of our centers which you know we
have five open right now we have our
sixth location opening up shortly
and two after the new year we like to
have art actually taken
from within about three miles of each
center so not only will you see you know
kind of nature photos
but you'll see landmarks that are
relevant to the center itself so dr
wakefield let's talk about senior
focused care that's that's your slogan
right
absolutely and and seniors have really
unique needs um
you know as we age we may have more
issues with mobility
and let's just take in the example of
our scale here it's really a wheelchair
scale because some patients actually
arrive in wheelchairs and as you can
know they can't stand up and necessarily
get their weight taken on a traditional
scale but it's still really important
for patients to get weighed
so actually they can just roll their the
wheelchair up there and get the total
weight
so as you can see in traditional offices
you'll often find people siloed into you
know private offices
but we're really about a care team
approach so it's important that we
collaborate
have constant communication with each
other so that we really can address all
the patients needs
and make sure that we can you know keep
things rolling in a
in a forward direction with our patients
so it really is all about collaboration
may i have a seat absolutely have a seat
on one of our brewers chairs
comfortable it is comfortable and i
think the main thing for us is again
remember
we we have you know a focus on seniors
our senior focused care
so we really want the things in our
clinic to really align with that
ability to take care of seniors so dr
whitefield i know partners in primary
care it's not just medical it's also
social right
right and when you look at our centers
right they're building people's
neighborhoods and so we really want them
to feel like an extension of their
neighborhood
so they can come here for things other
than their just their health care needs
and i know you have a community center
in each facility where people can come
and gather
once they can right right now a little
bit challenging during
the pandemic but yes we have a community
center where typically we would have
things like bingo night or football
night
things that they could enjoy outside of
not you know just not getting their
health care needs
give partners in primary care a call for
more information
702-623-3774
or visit seniorfocuslasvegas.com
we'll be right